ladies and gentlemen please welcome host  of the reuben report author of don't  burn this country and new floridian dave  rubin  so they're out there and if you saw  these people they're they're chanting  they're literally chanting we  say  gay  at my show  i don't just say it i mean i'm doing it  you know what i mean  disney has lost 41  billion dollars  donald  duck  is wandering the streets of orlando  sucking dick for a hot lunch  how many of you are conservatives  okay conservatives that basically means  you have a job  so  good for you guys then very very mean  and very scary  ben shapiro is four foot six okay  he's actually in my pocket right now  you guys want to see him  [Music]  you